white house says it believes
three ufos it shot down this
weekend were not spying.
>> Up first for us, though, rage
and reckoning in Michigan.
That after a mass shooter leaves
a killer's imprint on a large
college campus.
Three are dead, five more
wounded critically after a
gunman hunted students in two
buildings at Mish misstate.
The doctors trying to keep them
alive exhausted and emotional.
>> Can't forget we had general
surgeons, cardiothoracic
surgeons, neurosurgeons.
>> Didn't get a lot of sleep
last night.
Sorry.
So many people that just came
in.
>> Throughout the morning, some
new details about the ongoing
CSI.
Calls of shots fired came in a
little before 8:30 last night.
Police swarmed.
Students spent hours locked down
without knowing whether their
friends were dead or alive or
not knowing if the shooter might
walk through their door.
Today, police putting the name
to the images of the suspect,
43-year-old Anthony Mcrae.
The shooter, police say, never
attended, never taught, and
never worked at the school.
Let's get straight to CNN's
Shimon prokupecz for the latest
details.
>> And it appears he is from
that area, John.
So that's a significant clue for
authorities, perhaps he may have
been to the area before.
Because when you look at the
surveillance photo that police
released and some of the
information that they have been
releasing, how he went from one
campus, one building to the
other building, there's some
indication perhaps that he knew
where he was going.
The other significant
information we're just learning
from police there in Michigan
state is that they have
recovered a note, a note they
believe that was written by the
shooter, which will hopefully
for them shed some light perhaps
on what happened here, perhaps
describing some grievances that
he may have had, some concerns
that he may have had.
But again, the motive here
remains a mystery.
Police saying this morning
they're not any closer to
knowing why he targeted this
school.
But this note certainly is going
to be important for authorities
as they work through motive and
try to learn more about this
gunman.
What they have been doing, John,
is they have been talking to
family members, and others who
know this gunman, who know the
shooter, and it sounds like from
their information, from the
family, that certain this was a
troubled individual.
Family member describing him as
sort of secluded, kind of to
himself.
There was some trouble after his
mother died, according to his
father.
It sounds like for authorities,
at least, they're learning more
about the shooter here.
And at some point, maybe, and we
may not know ultimately what the
motive is here, but certainly,
we hope to hear more from
authorities.
Other thing very important here,
obviously, for the victims, that
community, and what they're
going through.
All of the victims here students
of the school, the three dead
and five that remain in the
hospital.
You can see the emotion from the
doctors.
You know, who see all sorts of
trauma, see all sorts of issues,
to sort of give that kind of
emotional statement and to talk
about it in that way, it tells
you the effect this is having on
the community.
>> Without a doubt.
Shimon prokupecz, appreciate the
live reporting.
Let's get expertise from two law
enforcement experts.
Former deputy director of the
FBI, Andrew Mccray, and Juliette
kayyem.
There's a lot we don't know, but
here, Anthony Mcrae, in 2019,
arrested, charged with a felony
for carrying a concealed weapon.
He pleaded to a misdemeanor and
once his probation was up, his
probation ended in may 2021.
So he had a gun charge on his
record.
May 2021, probation ends, then
you hear his sister calling him
isolated.
His father calling him evil
angry after his mother died.
Why is the system still unable
to connect this piece of
information with this piece of
information and say this man
should not have a gun?
>> Sure, so it comes down to
those regulations that are
enshrined in the Brady act of
1993.
That sets the parameters for how
background checks are done for
gun purposes.
Michigan is one of most states
that relies on the FBI to
conduct those background checks.
In this case, on the facts that
we know from the reporting about
this man, the arrest for felony
gun possession had they
convicted him of felony gun
possession, might have prevented
him from ever legally purchasing
a firearm again.
Looks like they pled that charge
to a misdemeanor, and a
misdemeanor conviction is not
enough to prohibit you from
buying a firearm.
It looks like it was a term in
his probation he was not allowed
to have guns while he was on
probation.
As you mentioned, he completed
that probation, so essentially
after that date, he could, as
mentally disturbed as he might
have been, as angry and, you
know, rage filled as he might
have been, he could walk into
any federally licensed firearms
dealer and purchase another gun.
>> Juliette, you and Andy and I
have had this conversation far
too many times.
Both in your work in government
and in the private sector, you
have worked on hardening these
sites, on improving security on
places that mass shooters
target.
Let's listen to one of the many
survivors here.
Listen to the fear.
>> Right when that first gun
shot went off, I booked to the
far corner of the class.
I was sitting right next to the
door where he came in,
literally, one of the first two
seats, he came in.
And I think my fight or flight
response kicked in because I
booked to the far side of the
class and ducked down.
He aim in and shot three or four
times in our classroom.
>> Often we're having this
conversation about elementary
schools or high schools.
This is a college campus.
50,000 students.
5700 faculty.
5200 acre campus.
What can and obviously in this
case, what can't you do to make
it safer?
>> Yeah, I mean, you're
basically going to have some
level of vulnerability.
You're not going to be able to
make these colleges and
universities safe because
honestly you don't want them
safe.
The kids, they hang out outside.
They go to concerts, there's
theaters, sports, classrooms
themselves.
What colleges and universities
are doing are they're trying to
fortify places where people
congregate, whether it's a
classroom or a dorm situation.
But you're always going to have
vulnerabilities given the size
of this.
And this university, obviously,
has main streets going through
it.
It has bicycles, it's a mini
city.
That's a challenge at this
stage, and we will learn whether
there were vulnerabilities that
could have been closed by the
university that may have
minimized the harm.
Someone determined to get into
one of these will likely be able
to get into one of these
buildings.
And that is a challenge.
I don't mean to be pessimistic
about it, but what that means is
then, what we have to do is work
on what the response capacity
can be.
I think you saw a pretty -- sort
of a near perfect response in
terms of the surge of resources.
I did think with kids, this is
generation lockdown, k-12,
they're now in college and it's
following them.
That's what we gave these kids.
And that's the tragedy of this.
These are the kids that grew up
post columbine.
>> If you go through the
timeline, first reports shots at
8:30.
A suspect description tweeted at
9:39.
Suspect located and died of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound at
11:35.
To your point, generation
lockdown, they put out a
photograph, and they get a tip
pretty quick.
So it sounds demented to say
this, they did the best they
could under horrific
circumstances.
>> They did the best, that's
right.
Your standards in my world are
can we make it less bad?
I think the university really
did.
Their preplanning with the
locals and then the state and
then we saw federal assets come
in seemed perfect.
I wanted to pick up on one point
we often don't talk about,
communication.
I was monitoring in real time.
They're doing everything you
would want to do, which is get
to the students, tell them what
to do, get to the faculty and
then colleges and universities,
these are kids still.
And get to the parents, and
telling the parents, do not come
to campus because it's a danger
zone, so to speak.
All of that is so important in
that timeline that we saw.
How short it was, was because
everyone knew what to do.
>> Andy Mccabe, as you're trying
to answer the question why, to
get to a motive, the police on
campus say no connection.
Didn't go to school there,
didn't teach there, didn't work
there.
But did, as Shimon noted, have a
note in his pocket, apparently,
threatening some schools in new
Jersey.
How do you try to piece together
why?
Why this gunman decided to go to
this campus late in the evening
and open fire.
>> John, we do this
investigation only for that
reason.
There's no one to charge here.
He's dead.
He's not going to jail.
But people have a desperate need
to know why.
Why this place, why these
victims, why this night.
And so what the investigators
will do is they'll go back and
execute search warrants at his
residence, maybe on his
vehicles, they'll look in all
his electronic devices, they're
course through if he has ever
used social media, what sort of
things he's powed or said or
liked.
They'll look at all his
writings, try to interview
family members and friends and
work associated all to answer
that question of why.
Maybe we'll get an answer, maybe
we won't.
The other question we should be
asking is how.
How does this happen?
How does it happen 60 or so
times this year alone?
And the answer is because we
have 120 guns in this country
for every 100 people.
We have more than double the
number of the second most gun
soaked country on Earth, which
is Yemen, not some place I think
we should be comparing ourselves
to.
Every lawful gun owner in this
country of which I am one, I
carried a gun every day for 21
years on the job, I own a
firearm, every lawful gun owner
should stand up and say enough
is enough.
We need actually effective laws,
actually effective background